[Music]
hello and welcome to a special hour-long
program answering your questions on
omicron it has been almost a fortnight
since the latest covid variant was first
identified in south africa little's yet
known about the heavily mutated strain
but it is perfectly plausible that it's
more transmissible and more resistant to
our vaccines
this hour i'm joined by the jcbi's
deputy chair professor anthony handen by
helen donovan from the royal college of
nursing genetic epidemiology professor
tim spector and professor robert west
who advises sage on behavioral health
psychology
now throughout the day we've been
getting your questions about omicron
questions about how virulent it is
whether our jabs are effective and
whether christmas might be cancelled
this year this is our omicron variant q
a just how worried should we be
i'm pretty confident or absolutely
confident this christmas will be
considerably better than last
there is no time to delay it's our
opportunity to get ahead i just hope we
don't go into another lockdown to be
honest even the large number of
mutations is highly possible at the
efficacy of a vaccine all of them is
going down
i'm scared of it
globally we have a toxic mix of low
vaccine coverage and very low testing
our strategy is all about buying time
have you got boosted yet now i'm 64 and
i feel like i'm walking with you come on
so where are we now well the number of
omicron cases detected in the uk has
risen again to 32 with a further 10 in
england and scotland identified
altogether at least 23 countries have
reported cases and the who expects that
number to rise early indications show
people are experiencing mild symptoms
with further data on the variant in the
coming days
well let's bring in our panel now
joining us uh to begin with professor
tim spector and professor robert west
thank you uh to both of them let's start
with our first question then shall we
from justin
who has asked just how deadly is omicron
how transmissible it is and should we be
prepared for a huge wave of cases
professor tim spector let me put that
one to you first
well
the real answer is we don't know for
sure
um
we
believe that it's probably more
transmissible than the current variant
which is delta
uh just in the same way that delta was
more transmissible than alpha
but
more than that we don't know exactly by
whether it's 10 more or 50 percent more
that still remains to be determined most
people believe it
the natural evolution is going to be in
that direction
in terms of severity uh whether more
likely to take the hospital or not um
everything so far looks that it's not
likely to be more severe
uh it'll either be the same
or slightly milder than the
other variants the the current delta
variant again
we're basing this on very small amounts
of information and so but
i think people who are worried about it
being a real deadly fatal variant that
transmits wildly there's no evidence
that that's the case at all so i think
so far people shouldn't be over worried
about this not panic about it and it's
we've gone through this variant
transition before
and you know cases picked up but
actually severity slightly dropped
and tim obviously there's still a lot we
don't know about this variant including
really how long it has been circulating
for but if as some suspect it's been
circulating
for longer than we initially thought why
steve asks are we not seeing higher
cases or hospitalizations why
are we worried at all i mean south
africa today
tim has seen a doubling of cases but
hospitalizations remaining broadly fr
flat there
yes
well you've got to realize that
hospitalizations tend to lag
new cases anyway by a couple of weeks so
you don't tend to see the hospitals
filling up until the virus has been
around for you know two to four weeks
but
remember actually south africa has less
cases per million than than we do in the
uk
um and most people believe the virus has
been around for perhaps uh
you know up to four weeks
and hasn't gone wild everywhere so in a
way that's somewhat reassuring
and we have to remember also that the uk
currently has
around 40 000 confirmed cases or
according to our
zoe study
about 80 000 cases that's remained
pretty high
and so
for for the new variant to take over
it's probably got to
displace delta
uh and many people are
have immunity natural immunity from
delta so it will be harder for it to
take over so i think
you know we are going to see more cases
but i don't see it exploding in perhaps
the way it would have done if before
we'd been infected with other ones or
before
most of the country got vaccinated
let's bring in professor anthony handen
deputy chair of the jcpi now and pick up
on that question uh that's not professor
handen is it let's bring him in and i
want to pick up professor handen with
you on that question about whether or
not this will become uh the most
infectious whether this will become a
dominant variant we've got a question
from trent
from berlin asking whether it's possible
that a more infectious but less deadly
covid19 variant could have a positive
impact this has been raised
by an epidemiologist in germany among
others hasn't it that that could a
highly transmissible variant with milder
symptoms actually bring a more rapid end
to the pandemic
uh it's possible i mean all things are
possible i mean there's three key things
that we don't know about this
new variant one whether it has a
transmission advantage over delta
to whether there is a degree of vaccine
escape or not i think by looking at the
mutations on the spike protein
many of which are mutations about
antibody
reception it probably has got a degree
of vaccine escape and the third question
which is probably the most important of
all
is what sort of disease severity does
the variant cause and that we don't know
so if
if it causes severe disease that's
hospitalization and deaths and has
vaccine escape then obviously that's not
very good news but we
we're hoping really that it doesn't
cause severe disease and that by
boosting the immunity of the whole
population
by giving them a boost of vaccine
they'll have high enough immunity levels
to actually
be able to partially fight off the
infection should they get and get it and
get a mild illness
so lots of uncertainties around the
variant but um
but there's good reason to be optimistic
if we get vaccinated well i was going to
ask you anthony about the data that
we're working with at the moment small
samples
being studied
what do they
tell us so far
about where we might be heading and how
much more do we need
well all they're telling us so far
because it really they really are small
numbers and it is very early stages
is that the this particular variant has
a number of mutations on this spike
protein which is the bit that the
vaccines target
um
that that cause one cause uh the the
mutations which affect the receptor
binding antigen so how it gets into the
cell but also the antibody receiving
part of the uh spy protein so so
um all the indications so far are that
is of concern which is why it's been a
variant of concern and why we've moved
very quickly um to
accelerate
the booster vaccination program and
professor tim spector i want to talk to
you about uh symptoms because that's
something that you've been studying with
the kovid
the zoe study throughout the course of
this pandemic shaheen in west london has
asked about the kind of symptoms we're
seeing with omicron suggestions of aches
and pains but no loss of taste and smell
what do we know so far and what does
that mean for our official
symptoms list and identifying these
cases
well we've had problems with the symptom
list
for
many months now in the uk because
40 percent of people who are testing
positive in the uk
don't have any of the classic symptoms
anyway so this is part of the natural
uh
current delta virus is that it is a
mixture of symptoms and increasingly
with vaccinated people and young people
uh
the picture is much closer to a
respiratory virus than the
uh original symptoms we got which was
much more uh sort of general malaise all
over the body
most of it is looking like a bad coal
for as i said about half the people who
get it in the uk at the moment
now
most unfortunately you can't officially
still get a pcr test in the uk
if you don't have the classic symptoms
so that's why we think
uh 40 of cases are still going
missing a lot in the uk
and if we look at the south african data
which
is still very limited in terms of
numbers uh they're suggesting that it it
it is looking like the the zoe picture
of the disease which is more respiratory
uh
type of symptoms more like a cold and
they haven't yet seen loss of taste or
smell but it could just be that they've
got very small numbers
currently
number taste loss of taste or smell is
the
about the number six uh
in our symptom list in delta
and fever is number seven so uh with
small numbers you might be missing that
so i think it's too early to say but
you know we we hope that with the zoe uh
kovis study people reporting their
symptoms and with the government telling
them if they have the new variant or not
we'll very quickly know the answer uh
within a couple of weeks about whether
we need to look for new symptoms but
people need to be alert and
and think if they're unwell you know
just the possibility that this could be
a new variant of covert they weren't
expecting it it's difficult isn't it in
winter with the number of respiratory
infections that are circulating i just
want to bring in our science
correspondent thomas moore now who's
here in the studio with me and thomas
you've throughout the day been taking
questions uh from viewers who've been
contacting you through the website
and on social media
what are the the main burning issues i
think a lot of people are confused that
they're getting such conflicting advice
from scientists some saying that this
could be really really bad that this has
the hallmarks of an extremely dangerous
virus whereas others think that it's
going to be okay that the vaccine
vaccines should still work
that there are many reports of very mild
disease in africa and of course the two
aren't necessarily conflicting
scientists are in a fog a lock of lack
of knowledge and they're trying to make
an educated guess to navigate their way
through others want to know how they can
be tested uh you know
how can you tell the difference between
omicron and delta particularly because
you have to self-isolate if you're a
contact of a suspected omicron case how
do you know precisely that and
fortunately in our favor is the fact
that the pcr test uh can tell the
difference because there's one
particular gene that drops out uh if if
it's uh omicron and that's going to be
the way forward but there are many
others just wanting to know how on earth
they can
look forward to a wedding or christmas
or any event like that
given the uncertainty given
the fact that we don't know what the
government's going to do in three weeks
time whether it needs to ramp up the
restrictions still further based on the
evidence emerging not just in south
africa but in labs around the world
three weeks time of course taking us
right up to christmas uh thomas is going
to be back with us a little bit later on
in the program but coming up
[Music]
the uk led the world in rolling out
vaccines early and in big numbers it has
one of the best vaccination rates in
europe but there are fears the new
omicron variant could put a significant
dent into that hard-earned protection
vaccine developers will be looking
closely at the new mutations
most of the available that needs to be
known but uh every day you learn more so
i'm very very very confident that uh
this
drug
works for all known mutations including
the omigran one but we are working on
follow-up
drugs
for the eventual case that maybe the
resistance is developed
we believe this virus is highly
infectious
we need to get more data to confirm this
but it seems to be much more infectious
than delta which of course is
problematic
and we also believe that it's already
present in most countries given the
large number of mutations it is highly
possible at the efficacy of a vaccine
all of them is going down but we need to
wait for the data to know if this is
true and how much is it going down
so what can we do about the omicron
variant let's put some more of your
questions to our panel of experts
professor anthony handen to you first a
question from yasmin from east london
she's asking whether the new variant can
evade the vaccines that have already
been developed and rolled out
how confident are we that they're going
to work
well we we just don't know the answer to
that question but we do know that these
covid vaccines that we've administered
in this country very successfully as
you've said
are highly effective at preventing
severe disease that's hospitalization
and death amongst those that have been
completed their primary course
so we fully expect with boosting that
there will be a degree of vaccine
protection against this variant even if
it's not complete
the population we really need to worry
about the most are those small
proportion of this country but
significant numbers that are
unvaccinated
and now is the time to come ahead come
forward and get your vaccination because
there's no doubt that if you're
unvaccinated you are not protected
whereas if you're vaccinated you will
have some degree of protection against
this new variant and if you're boosted
that protection will be even more well
let's put that issue to professor robert
west because i think there's five
million people in this country who are
eligible for a vaccine
robert but haven't yet taken up that
opportunity
many will have had a long time to to
think about it now how do we
target them how does the government try
and persuade them to get the vaccine
yeah well i mean there's different
groups within that five million there
will be a small group unfortunately
in this country it is a small group um
of people who sort of set their face
against vaccination for various reasons
they believed
some of the nonsense that they've heard
on social media and so on or they you
know they just start with a with a
particular point of view and there's no
shaking that that's a very small group
most of the people who haven't been
vaccinated yet will be people who are
genuinely weighing up the pros and cons
or um they they would get vaccinated if
for example it was a bit easier to do so
um if for example uh they knew that you
know because the vaccine does have side
effects and they may need to take a day
off work or two days off work if that
could be made easier for them so i think
there's plenty of scope there for
working with those people understanding
why it is that they're not uh yet taking
the vaccine and um
and supporting them and encouraging them
to do so but we do have to remember
that the vaccine is not the only thing
here the vaccine will give a
serious level of protection but it
certainly won't be the only solution we
need to look at all the other things
that we've been talking about mask
wearing is really important very
effective um ventilation in in indoor
spaces and making sure that you don't
unnecessarily put yourself in contact
with other people who might be infected
well that leads me on tim spector to a
question from rex who asked why we're
we're doing a big push to try and get
all adults boosted before a potential
omicron wave shouldn't we start with
work from home or restrictions on social
gatherings
um if your only objective was to
suppress uh an outbreak that's what
probably you would do yes and um
some countries have done that and uh
across in europe
and they've had real restrictions and
you know there are differences between
wales scotland and england in terms of
large social gatherings so
it tends to often be a political
decision rather than a purely a medical
one
politicians are deciding that that would
be
perhaps less popular for them or that
uh it would have some economic uh
detriments for the country and they
don't want to do this at the moment or
they want to hold it in reserve think
that otherwise people would get fatigued
by this so
every every measure
has a small effect as we've heard so
all of these things including
social mobility the way just people
moving around a lot visiting other
people
uh have big impacts so
i think
if all of us can do a small amount then
we can all
uh reduce the risk and reduce these
outbreaks without really disrupting
our social lives to any great extent so
um
you know i think
it's good that the government has
finally
started to do things and
certainly many of us have been pushing
for them to be a bit more proactive
before the new variant came along but
uh i think
we should be looking at some of the the
restrictions where we don't make a lot
of sense because
you need a master to go in a supermarket
but you don't have to
need a mask to go
to the theater or the cinema where
you're sitting next to people for uh you
know two or three hours
rather than just five minutes so i think
that needs to be sorted out and i think
people would accept
uh these kind of measures perhaps more
than the government uh given credit for
and i think this is probably where we'd
be going on moving forward of course
working from home many people have got
used to that and uh
particularly but also doing natural flow
tests before you go to any large meeting
and and that's something that
as we approach christmas parties and
things people are going to perhaps want
to be thinking about they should be
planning these a bit uh more carefully
and so if you have a cold or you've got
uh you know a natural flow positive
you're not going to be mixing with
50 other people
and let's bring in helen donovan now the
royal college of nurses you'll have seen
her pop up while tim was speaking there
helen thanks very much indeed uh for
joining us um let's talk about the
vaccine roll out and the capacity that
the nhs has for it stephen has asked
about boosters and jabs he's had both
jabs and a booster will he need another
vaccine if it is uh developed and nimrod
shaheed from southampton has also asked
do i still have to wait six months to
get a booster because me and others have
been turned away from vaccine
vaccination centers uh for coming too
early i know you're not responsible for
the specifics on it but in terms of the
policy
when can people get those vaccines what
are the priorities
well so um in answer to the first
question i think you know we don't know
whether we're going to need further
boosters doses and further vaccines as
time goes on and but right from the
beginning of the the vaccine program for
for kovic 19 we've had the the
suggestion that that may well be a
possibility so i think in answer to the
first question you know it's highly
likely but you know the evidence is
still coming through and we will still
have to wait and see i think in terms of
when people should come forward i think
it's still really clear that we need to
make sure that the elderly and people
with
underlying health conditions
get the vaccine as soon as possible and
they need to be prioritized and yes the
guidance has changed so we can start
giving people booster doses after three
months but obviously those processes and
the sort of operational side of that um
is coming through so i think there is a
need to
still be a little bit patient um it will
be coming through in the next few weeks
um and obviously we want people to turn
up we want people to
access the services as they come come
through but as we know the the nhs
system and the vaccine program itself is
really now ramping up the capacity
um and you know that's alongside all of
the other things that the health and
care system need to do
so i think you know in relation to what
other speakers have said about we all
need to do our part i think there's an
element of just you know go with it
and make
sure
that
we
we
still
i think we're losing you then those
people who are highly still on offer you
know the evergreen offer is still there
so sorry priority on yeah we're slightly
losing your line but a priority on those
who haven't yet taken up uh the offer of
a vaccine getting those through and
getting at the over 40s their boosters
and then working down uh through the age
ranges and
i wonder then
if i can bring you back in uh robert
west and and as the government pushes
harder and harder for people to get
jabbed and to get boosted are we in
danger of creating a two-tier society
the haves and the have-nots and how we
deal with that
there is a risk i think that um you know
there are demographic differences
between um you know people who are more
or less likely to get the vaccine but
actually they're not that great and and
i think it's more a question of
addressing the specific um concerns that
people have that some people have
about the vaccine rather than worrying
too much about you know whole sectors of
society but on the other hand you know i
do agree with you that um we already
have uh you know a two-tier or
multi-tier system in this country in
terms of the impact that kovid has had
and that the restrictions have had and
one of the problems
that we faced is that uh you know to be
fair i don't really think that the
government has done enough to compensate
people who've had their lives completely
disrupted or would have their lives
disrupted if they had to sell wisely one
of the big weeks and the weaknesses in
the in the uh
chain of events that needs to happen to
protect people is a failure to make sure
that people have the support that they
need if they need to self-isolate and
that's something that still needs to be
addressed but i think you know overall
what we're looking at going forward is
uh individuals government and all
members of society taking responsibility
all of us
taking responsibility to do the little
bits that we can to protect ourselves
and other people mask wearing
ventilation social distancing where we
can um step working at home where we can
um and just you know
treating it like a sort of you know we
would in road safety you know you don't
cross the road without looking both ways
it's a risk management exercise and our
job is to keep our risk as low as we can
possibly get it just one very brief
final thought from you robert on the is
david davis described it today as a
biological arms race over vaccines how
much tolerance do you think the public
have to to keep on being jabbed if this
is the way we are heading
yeah
they will do it i mean it's you know
people are not stupid
and um you know you do what you have to
you know all of us you know life throws
you know uh um brick bats at us and and
we say well okay this is where we are
this is what we have to do and what's
really been so interesting over the
course of pandemic is how far the public
has actually if anything been ahead of
the government in terms of saying you
know this is what we need to do to keep
ourselves
safe and then the government has sort of
caught up with them so i i think as long
as the government government doesn't
sort of mess it up in terms of
communications i think there's every
reason to believe that people will just
do what they have to do
okay we're going to take a short break
at the panel staying with us because
coming up next on sky news despite
global efforts to roll out vaccines
we'll be asking where did omicron come
from and is it here to stay
this virus has demonstrated that it will
not
simply disappear how many more lives and
livelihoods it takes is up to us
[Music]
welcome back to our special program
answering all your questions about the
new omicron kovid variant i'm joined by
a panel of medical and scientific
experts to do just that now omicron was
first identified in south africa and the
alarm was raised to the world health
organization last thursday it sparked a
global race to try to contain it with
many countries banning entries from
several southern african nations
while many wealthy countries enjoy
strong vaccination rates there are
concerns that lower rates in the
developing world will only prolong the
pandemic
globally
we have a toxic mix of low vaccine
coverage
and very low testing
a recipe for breeding and amplifying
variants
that's why we continue to urge countries
to fully fund the act accelerator
to ensure equitable access to vaccines
tests therapeutics
all over the world
this virus has demonstrated that it will
not
simply disappear
how many more lives and livelihoods it
takes is up to us ending the pandemic is
not a matter of chance
it is a matter of
choice
so how did we get here a question sent
in for you professor tim spector asking
how this happened how did omicron emerge
and why is it overtaking the delta
variant if indeed it is
well we don't know uh is the answer well
we
we're trying to piece it together from
the
the very astute surveillance of the
south african
uh genetics teams that picked it up uh
before any other country
and we don't even know it came from
south africa or botswana where
those first gates were picked up
we'll probably find some stored samples
somewhere where uh
it it was around before then but
most people believe it is somewhere in
the african area just because of the
density of cases but
you know some of these cases in europe
look as if they've been
around for several weeks
and uh that's a bit of a mystery so
we don't know for sure whether it's
going to out-compete delta either
and
uh it's very unclear from the south
african data
well that's true we do know from some of
the cases that
we're seeing from israel that some uh
cases of of people with
actually boosters have also got the
disease but they've got it very mildly
and i think that's that's about all we
know at the moment so
no one really knows the these uh
these variations could have arisen in a
single patient say he was
immunocompromised had it for maybe weeks
or it could have just been a consequence
of
of countries like the uk in the last
three months that have had high levels
of cases
uh and many chances for viruses to fight
against uh vaccinated people and
and uh develop these mutations to help
it reproduce and survive so
we really don't know uh it's all
guesswork at the moment we we likely
will never really find out uh where case
zero came from
we have got though tim spector haven't
we this this interesting situation in
the hong kong
quarantine facility where we've got two
cases
in separate quarantine rooms that have
emerged what does that tell us
potentially about the spread of this
variant
well it confirms what i was saying that
it's been around for several weeks
um and that it you know it's pretty
widespread
so uh it's you know airline
international travel has
spread this virus around and it's hard
to know which direction it actually came
from originally and i think we've got to
keep an open mind on this and and not
necessarily blame
uh south africa or these other african
countries uh for producing the variant i
think that's very counterproductive
and uh
if we do that it'll mean no one wants to
uh discover a new variant in case they
get
shunned internationally so and that was
a point made by the world health
organization today wasn't it we mustn't
penalize uh countries for sequencing and
identifying and alerting uh the world to
the presence of these variants a
question for you uh professor anthony
handen which has been sent in did
omicron really emerge because we didn't
share our vaccines with the developing
world i mean the issue of vaccine equity
or inequality is a really big one that
we haven't yet resolved
well of course the uk is one of the
biggest contributors internationally to
the to the vaccine stock i mean there
are a number of problems in uh
particularly in african countries it's
not just supply that's the issue
there's access to vaccines and that's
quite different actually it's quite
difficult to get people to the
vaccination centers
and then there is hesitancy
in many african countries about the
vaccinations
and myths and about
side effects etc so so there are a lot
of things that we need to get right but
yeah the presumption of your question is
right i mean we we do we're not going to
be safe until the whole world
has access to vaccines and we do want to
vaccinate the world i think that's
really really important
and so
what you're saying is is true i think we
need to both look after our uk
population which i'm responsible for but
we also need to be generous donation
donators given that we're a developed
and relatively wealthy country
to other nations and i'm sure our
government will will continue to do so
robert west a question from benji in
northwest london asking if this is
something we're going to have to get
used to or we're going to see a new
variant that causes changes to our lives
every winter and i suppose a
supplementary to that is how willing are
we to make those changes
when this all started um
uh it was widely believed by the experts
because of the nature of the virus
that we were in this for the long haul
um that there would be variants they
would come you know um out on a
fairly regular basis because it's but
it's unpredictable but you know to
expect that
um
that the fact that if we were able to
develop vaccines and it's fantastic that
we've been able to develop vaccines that
have had a high level of effectiveness
but they're not a hundred percent
effective so if we were able to develop
we we knew that that wouldn't be the
complete solution
so right from the beginning uh you know
those who know about these things were
saying you know we're going to have to
make adjustments in the long term we
don't know how long before you know the
word indefinitely sort of sounds rather
painful but you know the reality is for
the foreseeable future and those
adjustments don't need to be
restrictions of the sort you know not
lockdowns and things like that they need
to be the kind of adjustments to our
lives that we do for health and safety
to keep ourselves safe on the roads to
stop ourselves getting
infections when we go
into hospital and so on and this is
going to this is another risk that we
have to manage and that's what we're
going to have to do we just have to get
used to that um so it's you know it
doesn't have to be horrible for us but
we do have to take it seriously and and
to be honest uh you know we know that
people do adapt and we people will over
time we will find um
that we you know have ways of dealing
with these things that that means that
we can get on with our lives it's
incredible how much we have already
adapted if you think if you could have
told us two years ago where we'd be
today
and i just want to bring you but it's
still it's still tough you know it's no
doubt it is it is indeed let's bring in
thomas moore who's back in the studio
with us and thomas we say you've been
answering questions online uh all day
from people coming in but what are the
big questions for you
that remain to be answered over the
coming weeks look i mean we all want to
know well it's three key questions
really is it more transmissible does it
cause more severe symptoms does it evade
the vaccine is those three questions
that they are racing to try uh an answer
because it will determine our future are
we going backwards or can we continue as
we are everything hinges on those
questions and it's by no means certain
that what looks really bad on paper
turns out to be quite so bad in reality
it could be that this is a much milder
symptom a virus with much milder
symptoms in which case it won't lead to
lots more hospitalizations and even if
the vaccines don't prevent all
infections they might still prevent the
serious ones the ones that
put people
in hospital and might even result in
them dying and that would be good news
and we won't know until we can actually
test the virus against the vaccines
so not time to panic yet but as you were
describing earlier to us of course it's
very difficult because of the
conflicting messages we've been having
from the government from the scientists
we are in a knowledge fog and that is
the problem we're all trying to look at
those that that map of mutations trying
to judge whether there are any clues
from those mutations when they've arisen
in previous variants that might mean
that this is going to turn out to be
really bad but it's not just the number
of mutations it's how they work together
that will determine
how fit this variant really is whether
it stands up to
the vaccines the high level immunity
that we now have built up over the
previous 20 months of this pandemic
thomas thank you
we just
well welcome back to our special q a on
the new omicron kovid variant now the
big question for our panel of experts
and this has come in from so many people
as you can imagine asking will christmas
be cancelled this year i'm going to put
this to each of you and i'm going to
start with you helen donovan from the
royal college of nursing
the big concern is whether the nhs can
cope whether the nhs will be overwhelmed
and i guess at the moment it wouldn't
take that much would it for the nhs to
be overwhelmed how confident are you
about christmas
well i think you know thank you very
much for asking me first really um it's
the big question isn't it i think
everybody wants to make sure that we
have um some sort of
christmas but you know you're right the
nhs is under huge pressure as are other
healthcare services so i think going
back to some of the
responses to other questions what we all
need to do is to do our part to try and
keep ahead of the curve if you like
so vaccination being one part but also
wearing face coverings trying to make
sure that you keep in well-ventilated
spaces this this virus is spread by air
assaults so we want to make sure that
you know we minimize the risk of
transmission and i think all of these
measures that we're talking about are
all part and parcel of the overall aim
to make sure that we can
not just have christmas but
as the previous speaker was saying um
get on with our live is
because that's really important for all
sorts of things you know our mental
health um wider healthcare but but just
generally living so i think
um
the message must be get your vaccines
but also make sure that you take the
other precautions that we've been
talking about and you know wearing face
coverings making sure that you keep
social distancing as far as possible and
take sensible precautions just you know
it's a risk balance isn't it all the
time time
yeah
anthony honda and we had dr jenny
harry's yesterday suggesting people
should restrict their socializing around
christmas and then we had boris johnson
the prime minister and the government
saying well christmas can go ahead the
aim is is to get ahead
of this variant isn't it with with the
booster program but is that going to be
enough
well the vaccines can do a lot of the
heavy lifting sarah i mean what can i
just say i i do think you ought to do
this program in two weeks time when we
know a little bit more about this virus
because we will we will
see that we there's so many
uncertainties but i you know we're all
pretty fed up at this pandemic you know
we had christmas last year
when a couple of our children weren't
allowed to come home and and think and
we really don't want that anymore so i
i feel more positive i think these
vaccines are very good if people step up
in order in terms of vulnerability
get vaccinated with the booster and are
sensible
um with their uh precautions that social
distancing and um
and mass squaring and eventually i mean
it's cold out there isn't it so
ventilation is quite difficult but if
people are sensible then i don't see any
reason why we can't all enjoy christmas
again unless
um this vax this variant takes a real
turn for the worse and we're really not
going to know that for a couple of weeks
so have this program in a couple of
weeks and i'll tell you whether we're
going to have christmas or not but i
sincerely hope so by which point will
have bought the turkey we'll have all
the trimmings that the fridge and the
freezer will be full won't it uh anthony
we're gonna have christmas anyway aren't
we we're all gonna we're all gonna enjoy
it but what we want to do is enjoy with
with our our close family members and
and that that's the key really isn't it
so so don't don't stop buying your
turkeys and things because you will you
will have a
a christmas indoors i'm sure but let's
just hope that we can enjoy it with
other family members yeah and and robert
to you i mean at the moment we're told
that lockdowns are not on the table
christmas is is going ahead but if it
does come to that what do you think at
this stage in the pandemic compliance
would be like what does the modeling
tell you about
public tolerance for further
restrictions
well the uh it's always hard to predict
a hundred percent what people are going
to do in the future but if the past
predicts the future which it usually
does uh then if it were to come to that
then
the public compliance would be high
quite likely but i want to say that you
know it's worth bearing in mind
that we currently have around a thousand
deaths a week from covid without the
variant and there's no sign now that
we're seeing any kind of decline in that
because we've sort of reached a not an
equilibrium it goes up and it goes down
and so on but the situation absent of
the variant is still pretty dire and the
nhs is in real real trouble so
regardless of whether this variant turns
out to be worse or better or the same as
is expected we all have to do what we
need to do in order to keep infection
rates as low as we can make them
indefinitely what i would say about
christmas is that
all the holiday because christmas isn't
the only holiday that of course people
in this country uh celebrate at that
time um is i i personally
wouldn't make plans
that involve gatherings that can't be
changed in other words keep flexible
make your plans by all means as i am
but do it in a way which means that
should the worst comes the worst and we
have to make sure that people
stay apart from each other as much as
possible as it's safe
then you can still enjoy the holiday
period
yeah i mean that sounds a bit like deja
vu doesn't it those plans and then
cancelling those plans adapting those
plans at tim spector and nadia in west
london has asked along with many others
is another lockdown in the new year
inevitable so
perhaps we won't have as much
information as we need right before
christmas
but afterwards what do you think might
happen
yeah
looking at the uh
the data on the new cases from the zoe
app
they they're fairly steady although
admissions are slightly down
and so we're not seeing the severe cases
so i don't think anything's likely to
suddenly kick off in the next three
weeks but i do worry that
if we're not
more careful
uh or at least we're not as prudent you
know as we should be
there will be a pickup in the new year
and i think that's really more
the question here and that's going to
very much depend on whether
delta fizzles out because it's you know
basically uh infected most of the
population
or
the new variant is is going to
take over infect people that have
no longer have immunity
because they were infected with a
different virus or or uh vaccine waiting
so i'm more worried about uh january
than
uh
than than december but i'm hopeful we
won't have lockdowns because i i think
there isn't a lot of public appetite for
it what i think he's doing is doing
everything possible
to avoid lockdowns and we're still not
doing that yet in this country we're
still very reluctant to uh
stop very large indoor gatherings etc
and people just need to be more sensible
and start using these lateral flow tests
um and
getting boosters in the next few weeks
which is the thing that everyone can can
do for the most vulnerable i'm just
going to come we've only got 30 seconds
left but professor anthony honda a final
word from you on what we can all do to
give ourselves the best possible hope of
getting through this
well stay calm don't panic get
vaccinated
and and
try and be optimistic because i think
that if you can do all those things and
be sensible with your your your
lifestyle then then i think then we'll
get through this we'll we will get
through this as a country i'm absolutely
sure
thank you very much indeed and ending on
a note of optimism which is is what we
like to see professor anthony handen
jcbi's deputy chair helen donovan of the
royal college of nursing tim spector
genetic epidemiology professor and
professor robert west who advises sage
on behavioural issues thank you very
much indeed uh for answering our
questions here on sky news and we will
return to this as we get more
information about omicron coming up in
the next hour warnings that the number
of people waiting for